i'm gary stevenson former trader and
people's economist this is gary's
economics today we're going to explain
why the rich get richer
okay so there's a common misconception
that a lot of people have about why rich
people and rich families tend to get
richer and richer over time
people tend to believe
that getting rich is about
getting very good jobs very high paying
jobs
and it is true that most very
well-paying jobs are dominated by richer
people and people from rich families but
actually there's a much simpler reason
and more important structurally that
explains why rich people tend to get
rich and rich over time
and that is quite simply because
rich people own
all of the wealth all of the assets in
our country
and that forces poor and ordinary people
to give all or almost all of their money
to rich people every year we're gonna
explain this video how it works okay so
in this video we're gonna talk a lot
about wealth and it's important that you
understand what wealth is when we talk
about wealth we're not talking simply
about money we're talking about physical
assets such as
property the house or the flat that you
live in the office that you work in the
shops and the shopping centers and the
supermarkets in the city that you live
in and also natural resources like land
and oil and gas and coal
if you're not familiar with
understanding wealth as these physical
resources i recommend you go and watch
our video what is wealth which explains
really clearly what wealth is
so you understand what wealth is and you
know that the country is full of wealth
and that is largely
properties which is not just the
properties you live in but also where
you work and where you shop and it's
also natural resources like land also
crucially it's things like debt so for
example your mortgage that is wealth for
somebody who owns your mortgage and the
government debt is wealth for somebody
who lends money to the government
so this country is full of wealth
but most ordinary people don't own much
wealth if they're lucky they own the
property that they live in but they're
not likely to own vast amounts of
commercial wealth such as shopping
centres or skyscrapers or supermarkets
the vast majority of wealth that is
owned in the country is owned by very
rich people and if you look at stocks
and shares
who are the corporations who own
commercial property they're
overwhelmingly owned by richer people
so the first fact you need to understand
is that the vast majority of wealth and
assets in this country are owned by
richer people not ordinary people
so the next thing you need to know
is those assets
are often things which ordinary people
literally need so the most obvious case
is if you rent the property you live in
that is owned by a wealthy person you
need that property
and that generates a cash flow from you
an ordinary person to the person who
owns your property every month but even
if you do own your property but with a
large mortgage it's important to
understand that a rich person ultimately
owns your mortgage so every single month
you make interest payments they go from
you to that rich person
but it goes much deeper than that every
time you go to the supermarket and you
buy your groceries a big chunk of the
money you spend goes to the rich person
who owns a supermarket
also the rich people who own the land in
which the food was growing
and every time you pay your bills to
heat your home
a big chunk of that goes to the rich
person who owns the natural resources
which might be
the coal or the oil or it might be the
wind farm or the solar farm that
generates electricity so every time you
spend
basically any money
it's important to consider that that
money you spend is not
generally going to the workers
in that place you know in the case of
renting mortgages there are no workers
involved
every time you spend money in the
supermarket or in the shops a big chunk
of your money is going to richer people
so i think it's worth just sitting
and thinking about your personal
position for a little bit so for a lot
of people especially a lot of young
people
you'll get your
money from your job and you'll pay your
rent
or your mortgage if you're lucky enough
to own property you pay your bills
they'll not really be much left over i
mean especially now we're looking at
the cost the basic cost of living going
up significantly for a lot of people
literally your entire salary
is going to go on
paying these basic costs
and i want you to think about where does
that money go because it's very easy you
pay your mortgage and you don't think
where does this money end up but that
mortgage that you pay the interest
ultimately goes to a wealth individual
and when you go to the supermarket you
just think the money's gone but it goes
ultimately to the owners that
supermarket so if you're in a situation
where after paying for your basics 80 90
even close to 100 of your salary is gone
basically all of your salary
has gone to the owners of the assets
so all of the money that you make
goes directly to rich people i think
when you understand this it starts to
become
really obvious that even if rich people
don't have super good jobs they are
going to get rich every year because all
of your salary or the vast majority of
your salary goes pretty much straight to
them
just to keep you in a house and to keep
food on your table
so that's from the perspective of an
ordinary person a big chunk of your
salary goes basically directly back to
the rich when you pay your bills when
you pay more when you pay your rent
let's consider it from the perspective
of a very wealthy person so let's take
for example one of my favorite people in
public life today which is sunak who's
worth an approximately 200 million
pounds
he is receiving those payments right so
when you pay your rent it's going to
him or someone like him when you pay a
mortgage it's going to him or someone
like him every single time you go to the
supermarket every single time you pay
your bills it's going to him or someone
like him now if the wealth is very very
concentrated with really rich people
like russia sonat each one of those
people can receive an enormous amount of
money
so
he's worth 200 million pounds these
people typically make about three
percent a year on their income so on
their wealth so he's gonna make about
six million pounds
every year
just because he owns the assets because
he owns buildings because he has natural
resources because he maybe owns your
debts so
imagine you're risky sonak and remember
this six million pounds it's not money
he gets for working it's money he gets
because he owns
the stuff that you need and you have to
pay him to use it so he's getting six
million pounds every year every year
now imagine you're risky sonak and
you're getting six million pounds every
year just for getting out of bed
do you think he would get richer year
after year
well
you would
you would wouldn't you because if you're
making a six million pound income every
year
what are you going to do you're not
going to spend 6 million pounds a year
because that would be totally ridiculous
i like you couldn't even imagine how you
would even spend 6 million pounds a year
he's probably going to spend
half a million pounds a year live like
the queen who he is reputedly richer
than
and save five and a half million pounds
a year so
this mystery of why rich people get
richer it's actually much much more
simple than you think rich people get
richer because they own all of the
things that you use they own your house
they own your mortgage they own the
supermarket that you do your shopping in
they own the companies that provide your
electricity
they own
the cinema that you go to they own the
airplanes that you use when you go on
holiday they own everything that you use
and you give all of your money to them
because they own the stuff that you need
which means that they generate an
enormous amount of income from you
so again rishi sunak makes six million
pounds a year literally just for getting
out of bed because he owns the stuff
that you use and that money is
ultimately coming from you so when you
understand that rich people own all of
the assets and get all of your salary it
becomes pretty obvious that they're
going to get richer year after year
you make 30 grand a year you give all of
it to the rich people so you have
nothing to save they make 6 million
pounds a year it's obvious they're going
to accumulate money year after year
okay so these are the facts the rich
people own everything ordinary people
own very little ordinary people pay all
of their salary to the rich people every
year and rich people make millions of
pounds every year from that money
this means they accumulate a huge amount
of cash
it's important to understand what do
they then do with that cash because this
generates a real imbalance in society
right they keep accumulating more and
more and more cash but you need that
cash to live so how do you get that cash
back
now there's a few ways that cash flows
back from rich people to ordinary people
one way is rich people live really
luxurious lives right they go on really
luxurious holidays they maybe pay for a
lot of staff they go to very expensive
bars and restaurants they spend a lot of
money and that is one way that ordinary
money flows back from rich people to
ordinary people but if inequality gets
too high
you get a situation where
there's not that many rich people but
they're phenomenally rich you know if
there's
broadly equal society you can have a lot
of relatively rich people but if you
have a very unequal society you have a
very small number of extraordinarily
rich people now as people get richer and
richer their consumption doesn't go up
in a line so if you consider say jeff
bezos he's got a wealth of 200 billion
dollars he'll make about six billion
dollars a year he will spend a tiny tiny
fraction of that so as the rich get
richer and richer and richer they are
not able to spend enough money to get
that money circulating back through the
economy so what do they do
well one thing that they do is they use
it to buy assets but remember the rich
as a whole are buying assets so they
can't buy them from each other they need
to buy them from the rest of us poor and
ordinary people
so i think this plays out in quite an
interesting way which is
most of these very rich people are older
they have huge amounts of cash they give
that money to their kids which means if
you are a young person from a rich
family you can easily get a few hundred
grand from your parents to buy property
which means that house prices go up very
aggressively it means that if you're a
younger person from a poor ordinary
family housing becomes something you
can't possibly afford to buy and i think
this is interesting because people don't
really realize it's happening right
older people sell their property and
they don't realize it's only going to
rich people whereas younger people can't
buy property and they don't realize it's
because they're competing with young
people from rich families who are
getting huge amounts of cash from their
parents
but this creates a problem right if rich
people are using that money to buy
housing from poor and ordinary families
that's making the problem worse right
because it's transferring more wealth
from ordinary families to richer people
so if wealth equality is very high
the rich get a huge amount of cash from
ordinary people and they use that to buy
more wealth and assets from ordinary
people it means that wealth inequality
gets worse and worse and worse over time
the other thing that they do is they
lend that money out now that might sound
like a good thing right because if
they're lending a lot of money out you
might think okay but we can borrow that
money and then it'll be easier for us to
get mortgages and then it'll be easier
for us to buy houses but remember
if you can borrow more money from the
rich then so can everybody else and what
this means is you are competing with
people who can borrow huge amounts from
the rich which means you have to borrow
huge amounts in the rich and
increasingly we're seeing a situation
where for ordinary people the only way
to get a house is to borrow really truly
enormous amounts of money especially
here in london you have young people
borrowing half a million pounds to buy a
house so if rich people accumulate huge
amounts of cash they use that to buy
assets and indirectly force
ordinary people into debt in order to do
simple things like buy a house
so that money is used to push up asset
prices and also drive ordinary families
out of being able to own assets
but there's another problem
with these cash flows of inequality
which has become much more obvious
during coping
the cash flows that go from ordinary
people to rich people
many of them are legal obligations you
have to pay your rent you have to pay a
mortgage you have to pay your bills
but the cash flows that come back round
especially luxury spending is basically
totally optional for wealthy people
what this means is in a sense wealthy
people have a stranglehold on the
economy you need their money to pay your
bills but they have the complete choice
whether to give you their money or not
and we saw this during covert when
suddenly rich people were not allowed to
live lives of extreme luxury that meant
a huge number of people completely lost
their incomes and couldn't pay their
bills
and this could happen at any time
basically if the rich at any time decide
to suddenly significantly stop spending
money it will cause an economic disaster
for poor and ordinary people 2008 in
many ways was a similar crisis
when we have this situation where
ordinary people continually have to turn
money to the rich and the rich can
decide whether to turn money back our
economy is always on the verge of
collapse
okay so to conclude
rich families keep getting richer
because you have to give them basically
your entire paycheck every month
it's no more complicated than that that
means they accumulate a huge amount of
money from you your family and your
community every month every year they
use that money to buy your assets and
put you into debt what that means is if
you don't do anything about it they will
get richer and richer and richer and
richer and ordinary people will get
poorer and poorer and poorer and poorer
the consequences of that are exactly the
kind of consequences we're seeing now if
these guys are super rich and the rest
of us are super poor then they will
consume all the natural resources which
means that we will not be able to afford
basic things like food and heating
so
this is a really significant problem and
in the absence of any action against it
it will get worse and worse you know
it's kind of like a cancer in our
society it will only grow if we don't do
anything about it and what covert has
shown us
is it's created a massive massive
increase in inequality in a very short
period of time and it's showing us
really clearly what the consequences of
that are if inequality gets massively
bigger then ordinary people
will see their quality of life decrease
house prices will go up which will mean
ordinary people can't afford to buy
houses and increasingly if you do want a
house you have to take massive amounts
of debt
so
covert has made it really clear what
happens when inequality increases but i
think what i want to make clear in this
video is in the absence of any action
against it that will get worse and worse
and worse over time because as
inequality increases
fewer of us own assets which means we
have to pay more money to them which
means they will get richer which means
they will buy more of our assets
to conclude rich people get richer
because we give them all of our money
they use that money to make themselves
richer and us poorer if we don't do
anything about it things will get worse
and worse and worse so i would encourage
you please to support me and this
channel in pushing politicians to make a
wealth tax happen to make things more
equal going forward thank you
yeah
okay then we are done
you cannot be surprised when these
people turn to crime and these people
turn to dangerous means of getting it if
the best people were in the best jobs
then they've come from all throughout
society but right now they all come from
the same schools and the same families
[Music]